♪ ♪
>> Jesse: FOX NEWS HAS
CONFIRMED PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TOP
ECONOMIC ADVISOR GARY COHN HAS
RESIGNED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID GARY HAS
BEEN MY CHIEF ECONOMIC ADVISOR
AND DID A SUPERB JOB DRIVING OUR
AGENDA, HELPING DELIVER AN
HISTORIC TAX CUTS AND UNLEASHING
THE AMERICAN ECONOMY.
HE WAS A RARE TALENT AND I THINK
HIM -- SAYING HIM.
FROM MR. COHN, IT'S BEEN AN
HONOR TO SERVE MY COUNTRY AND
ENACT PRO-GROWTH POLICIES.
IN PARTICULAR, THE PASSAGE OF
HISTORIC TAX REFORM.
GRATEFUL FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
AND WISH THE PRESIDENT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION GREAT SUCCESS.
KIMBERLY, HE CAME FROM
GOLDMAN SACHS.
GREAT PEDIGREE.
VERY SUCCESSFUL ON WALL STREET.
HE WAS CONSIDERED WHAT PEOPLE
SAY OF THE WHITE HOUSE WHO
DIDN'T LIKE HIM, A GLOBALIST.
NOT AN AMERICAN NATIONALIST,
MORE CONCERNED ABOUT THE WORLD
ECONOMY AND NOT NECESSARILY A
DEFENDER OF THE AMERICAN
MANUFACTURING SECTOR.
HAD INTERNAL FLIGHTS WITH
MEMBERS OF THE ADMINISTRATION.
SOME PEOPLE ARE SPECULATING HE
MAY HAVE RESIGNED IN THE WAKE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYING HE IS
GOING TO ENACT STEEL TARIFFS.
>> Kimberly: I THINK HE'S
OBVIOUSLY A HIGHLY COMPETENT
INDIVIDUAL, WELL-REGARDED AT
GOLDMAN SACHS.
PEOPLE THOUGHT HE WAS MORE OF A
GLOBALIST.
I THINK HE IS SOMEBODY THAT
WANTED TO SERVE THE COUNTRY,
WORKED HARD.
THE PRESIDENT LIKED HIS
ORGANIZATION.
CHARTS, COLOR-CODED, HE LIKED
IT.
HE WAS VERY ORGANIZED.
I LIKE ORGANIZATION.
DANA PERINO LIKES ORGANIZATION.
THAT WAS VERY GOOD.
HE FELT HE HAD KIND OF PROVIDED
THE OPPORTUNITIES IN THE HELP
AND THE ASSISTANCE TO THE
PRESIDENT AND THE COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT MADE A TWEET
SAYING THERE MIGHT BE STAFF
CHANGES.
THIS WAS EXPECTED.
THERE WAS DISCUSSION ABOUT COHN,
McMASTER, AND CHIEF OF STAFF
JOHN KELLY.
YOU'RE ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE
LEAVING THE PRESIDENT.
I ALSO NOTE HE'S BEEN VERY CLOSE
WITH JARED AND IVANKA.
THAT WAS THAT -- LIKE A
TRIUMVIRATE.
HE WASN'T A BIG PROPONENT OF
EXITING THE TERRORISTS CLIMATE
HE KNOWS THE ECONOMY AND HE WAS
HELPFUL TO THE PRESIDENT IN THAT
REGARD.
WHAT DOES PRESIDENT TRUMP DO?
>> Jesse: ALWAYS HIRES THE
BEST PEOPLE.
>> Juan: [LAUGHS]
>> Jesse: WHAT IS SO FUNNY,
JUAN?
>> Juan: THAT IS HILARIOUS.
HOW MANY PEOPLE COME AND GO.
SO QUICKLY.
TO ME, WHAT KIMBERLY SAID ABOUT
KUSHNER'S AT THE FOREFRONT.
HE WAS PART OF THE KUSHNER WING
OF THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE.
KUSHNER IS ON VERY THIN ICE,
HAVING HIS SECURITY CLEARANCE
DOWNGRADED.
CAN'T REALLY FUNCTION PROPERLY
IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
CHARGES OF NEPOTISM.
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" SINGLE
HOME.
>> Kimberly: IVANKA WILL STAY.
>> Juan: GARY COHN IS SO
RESPECTED ON THE ECONOMIC SIDE,
NOW HE IS OUT.
IT IS CHAOTIC.
>> Jesse: MARKETS MIGHT NOT
LIKE IT.
>> Dana: I THINK HE'S BEEN A
LOYAL PUBLIC SERVANT.
WHEN YOU SAID, GLOBALIST CARES
MORE ABOUT THE GLOBAL ECONOMY
THAN THE AMERICAN ECONOMY, I
THINK HE WOULD SAY IT'S NOT
TRUE.
HE IS RESIGNING ON PRINCIPLE
BECAUSE HE CARES ABOUT THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY, ESPECIALLY TAX
REFORM AND DEREGULATION, VERY
MUCH HELPED THE UNITED STATES
ECONOMY.
ON PRINCIPLE, DECIDED TO RESIGN.
THAT'S WHEN YOU KNOW YOU HAVE A
LOYAL PUBLIC SERVANT.
IF YOU FEEL YOU'VE GIVEN YOUR
BEST ADVICE.
GUESS WHAT.
SORRY.
THE PRESIDENT IS THE PRESIDENT.
I CAN GIVE YOU MY BEST ADVICE
AND IF YOU DON'T TAKE IT, IF I
FEEL STRONGLY ENOUGH THAT IT'S A
BAD DECISION AND I SHOULD
RESIGN, I THINK WE SHOULD
WELCOME THAT.
DOESN'T ALWAYS HAPPEN THAT WAY
IN WASHINGTON.
>> Jesse: HE HAD A GOOD RUN ON
THE ECONOMIC SIDE.
>> Greg: THAT HE DID.
A TYPICAL GLOBALIST WOULD SAY
THAT, DANA.
THE POINT IS IF YOU WANT CHEAP
GOODS, GOODS PEOPLE CAN AFFORD
AND YOU WANT TO SPREAD THE
WEALTH, IF THAT MAKES YOU A
GLOBALIST, THEN YOU ARE A
GLOBALIST.
I AM SO TIRED OF THAT PHRASE.
I THINK THE PHRASE HAS BEEN,
IT'S BECOME A KNEE-JERK THING TO
SAY WHAT TRUMP ISN'T.
THE FACT IS, WE ARE ALL
GLOBALIST.
>> Kimberly: LIKE WE ARE ALL
DREAMERS?
>> Greg: WE ARE GLOBALIST
DREAMERS.